[Applause]
it's just checking here meet back so
yeah my name is Emma and I work at a
company and I could seem illogical we
make a system for robotic-assisted
keyhole surgery and we are hiring so the
link is there to loose it for engineers
and a scientist
I myself software engineer a team lead
there so not our data scientist so have
I ended up getting into high data so in
my spare time I've played around a bit
with some dates and stuff and some
machine learning for fun and and one of
the things I better play with was
genetic algorithms and in particular
seeing if I could use those to evolve
some code Robin after write it myself
and as a fairly obvious spoiler given
I'm giving the talk yes you can so that
was a pretty cool and be instantly
terrifying for my job security and so I
can evolve some code rather write it
it's a little bit like being a taxi
driver and being told that self-driving
cars are coming it's not great if we
look back over human history we see you
know we've frequently changed what sort
of work we do have certain work as a
result and rapid change in technology so
it used to be the case that you know the
vast majority of us but it worked in
food production just ensuring that we
had enough food to eat was a massively
labor intensive industry and then we
invented things like this and now you
know one person can sit in a combine
harvester and harvesters field as
opposed to you loads of people doing
that and it frees us up to work in other
areas and more recently you might have
walked into a shop and maybe even
presented with this so rather a bunch of
people at least ills now you've got
these self checkouts and you might be
thinking ok well that's you know it's
very rope routine tasks and more complex
things things that divor bits of
creativity linking different concepts
they're probably all right right we
probably still need humans to do those
but and with the advent of particular
physical intelligence increasingly
that's that's less the case and so if we
look back quite a few years now and so
this is IBM's Watson supercomputer so
they worked to list between about only
4th 2011
and they originally made it to compete
to the u.s. quiz show called Jeopardy
and so if you've not heard of that quiz
instead of being asked questions
you were given answers and you have to
figure out what the questions were so to
do that you need to be able to do a few
things first of all you need to
understand what was said to you you need
to put into context need to have some
general knowledge to draw from you know
back up your answer and make some
references and you need some get to make
some really obscure references and jumps
between topics as well and some weird
word associations and you might think
that kind of lateral thinking again more
suited to a human brain but no they got
Watson to not only play this game well
but to be all over human champions and
they did that using a combination of
natural language processing so it could
understand was said to it massive
database of knowledge and some very
efficient data mining techniques they
could very quickly query that and get
most relevant information they use
probabilistic reasoning and it's
iterative training cycles until they got
this to be producing yeah doing well at
jeopardy more interestingly since then
perhaps they put this it's more of
practical real-world uses any problem
where you've got a really large dataset
to search through Watson is greater so
for medical diagnostics where you have
huge vast amounts of data you've got you
know all medical text books we've got
journals you've got latest clinical
studies results you've got you know
individual patients medical records
registries of lots of patients records
no doctor human doctor can possibly keep
up with all that on top of their day job
but Watson you can keep feeling at that
data and it will never forget anything
that it learnt
so if particularly if you've got a
particularly rare condition look human
might not have come across in their
career Watson may be able to give them a
more accurate diagnosis than a human
could and it's also been used for legal
advice as a service so Watson's back end
internet chat bot was a front end to get
legal advice to people that might not
otherwise have been able to have access
to that again
vast amounts of data lots of rules for
just judgments that kind of stuff in a
classroom you can see it being used so
it can do natural language processing on
its own question it's got a huge data
to find the answer in so now we're
talking about doctors we're talking
about lawyers talk about teachers and
these are really well-respected skilled
professions and we're now saying that a
machine can do at least aspects of those
jobs potentially better than a person
again
so what about a software person and
hopefully okay do we are we needed to
write the code that makes these things
run but as I say it's looking at ways
that you could generate that code wrong
have to have a human right it and one
approach you might take is genetic
algorithms so what is a genetic
algorithm it is a type of guided random
search algorithm so as opposed to a
systematic search where say you've got
all your data here and you look from one
end and keep going until you find the
thing you want
which obviously might be very
inefficient and take a very long time if
it's very large data set and what you
want to over there and or as opposed to
a random search where you say oh it's
gonna look over there nope got there
okay what about here nope still up there
thank you going in a guided random
search you pick a point at random to
look and then you see well what is there
and then based on what you find there
you decide where to look next
so say if I look over here and I find
something that looks vaguely look like
what I'm looking for I might decide to
look in the vicinity at that point next
and for that to work you need the points
to have some relation to each other so
if I look this point here the point next
to it must be in some way related the
data needs to be kind of continuous and
in particular a genetic algorithm it's a
guided random search which takes
inspiration from biology specifically
from evolution where we have a side
there survival of the fittest so if I
can run quicker from Tigers or something
I'm more likely to survive and pass on
our genes to the next generation what on
earth does any of that have to do with
writing an algorithm that you can write
some code for you might ask and so let's
take a concrete example let's say I want
to evolve strings containing the title
of this talk so not program code to
start with just common or garden text
string so I can think of this as either
searching the space of all possible
strings until I find the one that has my
title or I can think of it in terms of
evolving
and so if we use the latter analogy and
what we're going to do first is we're
going to initialize a population of
random strings it lends different
characters and then we're gonna evaluate
those to see how much they look like the
strings were looking for and assigned
enough it's cool so this is where my
analogy of evolution step two it's
already completely gone out the window
and because we obviously don't normally
have an end goal and evolution but here
we are artificially crafting off fitness
function to steer it towards what we're
looking for and then going to select
which members of this population survive
through to the next round to pass on
their genes so there's a line you first
get back I might say well I'll order all
the population in order of their fitness
school and I'll take the best half and
I'll get rid of give us the next step is
something called crossover so this is
analogous to you getting half your
chromosomes from each parent so I might
for instance just take the first half of
one string a second or the other and
stick it together there's a really basic
first pass Pam I do that I then gonna
mutate the the child string that I've
created so this is in the same way that
you get can introduce new
characteristics and features and so
population through random gene mutations
I'm going to take this string and I'm
just going to randomly pick a few
characters and switch them out for the
characters and then I look over my
population how I got the string that I
want in it if yes great done stop if not
I'm gonna loop that around and keep
going that's pretty much it so let's so
what we've got here is the target string
that we're trying to get to the space
that we're searching is strings
consisting of printable characters with
a maximum length of 100 so any string up
to 1,100 printable characters that's all
that's our search base that's a big
search space and what I've done is I've
pulled out a general sort of genetic
algorithms function for use so this is
agnostic of what it is that you're
evolving so in this case all the sort of
stringy bits up here and we have a
Jessica
function that will reuse later for
programming evolution to which you can
pat in how are you going to generate the
candidates how are you gonna cross them
over how you're gonna work out when
you're done and the fitness score for
each one so if we look into that we can
see that for each one we're going to do
pretty much this is our flow chart from
before so we're going to generate our
population using the spawn function that
was passed in and then we're going to
print some population stats out just
this is just to help us see that
something is going on in our program so
this will just be things like the
minimum maximum average fitness
generation what size of populations that
kind of stuff and then we got to check
are we done
if so great print print our result that
we're looking for
if not let's select which ones get to be
live on to the next generation in our
simple case we're not gonna worry about
roulette selection I'll mention that
later sort of said we're just going to
pull the population and take the best
half then we're gonna breed them so we
will here we've passed in how we're
gonna come over and we'll just call that
to create sin the children here so
having all that things we're gonna pass
in or generating a random string so
we're gonna pass it or character set and
I maximum length and that will just pick
a random length for string and then for
that length go to random characters when
it comes to breeding strings we will
start with lot in a random split which
means we're gonna split at the halfway
point with the split string then we're
gonna take our two halves
first off of the first friend second off
on and mutators so a mutation to start
we're only worried about replacements
which means we're in this bet code so
we're just gonna have some set mutation
rate and
we're kind of generally around a number
if it's less than that mutation rate
then change the character out for a
different random one so are we gonna
stop when we get the thing that we want
and in terms of calculating or fitness
for each character in the output ideally
it matches our target and we're going to
penalize things that are the wrong
length so if you've got matching output
but then after it there's a lot of
jumbled nonsense characters then we
don't want that good thing we end up
with I'll switch to the terminal to run
it just cuz it gets me a bit more screen
real estate and so this hopefully we'll
get to the title of the talk so what
you'll see printed out for each
iteration is the population stats for
that generation and the best candidate
so to start with that will be something
around about the right length because we
were awarded that and I'll fake this
mention and so if everything is just
random
right now because we're gonna get and
then we should start to see some
features emerge like spaces in the right
places until we get all the one cool so
we have got two title of a stop using a
genetic algorithm that's nice but how do
we do something more interesting how do
we evolve program code so we're gonna
have small problems for program code so
before I could just dump a load of
random characters into a string and it
didn't look anything like my target
string probably but it was still a
string and whereas if I just dumped a
load of random characters into a text
file
the odds of that's runnable for a gram
code are pretty slim to none to be
honest so how are we gonna deal with
that so you might say okay well let's
try and use some templates let's get
this thing that looks like a for loop
this thing that looks like an if
statement will kind of fill in the
blanks and stick them together and fair
enough you will generate some random
program valid sorry programs if you do
that but as soon as you start crossing
them over in random places and mutating
them and stick them together very
quickly not going to be valid anymore so
you might say okay I'll embed my own
language
it will consist of a series of symbols
and I can put them in any order I like
so that will give you valid programs you
look probably unintentionally limited
what it is that you can program in that
language you've just created so we need
the language that we use to be something
called pure and complete because we want
to be able to program anything that we
would like in it if all the code that
could do whatever and so what do I mean
when I say too incomplete and so Alan
Turing did a lot of research into the
fear of computation specifically into
reprogramming machines and he came up
with a concept of a Turing machine which
is a mathematical models to help them
think about those and so you can what it
says it's basically an infinitely long
piece of tape divided into a series of
cells and then you have an arrow that
kind of points are given cell and you
can move that arrow along and when we're
looking at particular cell we can read
the value out of it
we can put a value in looking change the
values there that's pretty much it and
you should have mathematically that
anything that you could compute could be
computed with that machine as simple as
it sounds so not everything is
computable but if you can compute it you
can do so the Turing machine when we say
a language is during complete what we
mean is it can be used to simulate a
Turing machine and therefore anything
that could be computed can be computed
in that language so those are our
requirements then we're looking for an
incredibly syntactically simple but
curing complete language so at this
point I thought well that probably
exists and I'm gonna reinvent the wheel
I'll go and google it and I came across
this site so this primary object on
highly recommend it it's a great
collection of blog posts and articles on
machine learning there's a core
Rebekah's site I don't know I found an
article about exactly I was looking at
and to Cori had been working on
involving code rather than writing it
and she had identified the language I
could easily use for this and this
incredibly simple language has only
eight characters and is basically a
model of a Turing machine this is a
point where in the interest of not
swearing at Europe easily for the rest
of the talk I've sort of start out the
last bit of it you probably guess
if you can't guess star isn't a valid
character of variable names so I'm
afraid you are about the salesman code
so the first six characters that we have
in the instruction set for breath a
about the story machine so moving this
point to up and down changing the value
in the cell reading the value about the
last two characters the square braces
it's where things get interesting so
this is what gives the language its
power and ability to do control flow so
this lets us look at the value under the
current and the pointer and make a
decision do we want to keep looping or
do we want to skip pass into the loop so
that gives us our control flow and so
what does a program written in brain F
look like so if we consider our sort of
standard introduction to any new
language program so we're gonna go for
the world this is hello world and brain
F you can see how it got its name I
think writing this would be a bit of a
nightmare for something this simple it's
really just about do it reading it or
debugging it I don't want but to the
computer this is perfectly intelligible
this is just the second interpret let's
just apply than any other programming
language and indeed we can write a
Python interpreter for Braniff which I
have done so if we give a demo I'll show
you how this works in a minute sorry so
this indeed prints look how that works
so we start out with something that's
pretty much a disaster in machine class
so basically just moving pointers
forwards and backwards and getting
values and cells the interesting thing
to note is unlike our mathematical model
with this infant Li a long piece of tape
clearly our computer has a finite memory
so we have a finite tape length and that
means that you can when you move your
pointer for the backwards you can
potentially go off the end of that
finite tape
so we've defined a segmentation full
exception and you can throw that in that
case we'll move on to actual brain earth
code so this is a basically a Turing
machine where the various commands that
you get in the brain F language tell you
what instruction you should carry out
and interesting when we initialize this
we need to do something special for the
square braces so if we're going to be
jumping from the closing brace to the
opening brace we need to know where in
the program it was so we need to
basically just go and find what the
matching ones were this is one of the
few pretty much the only way actually
you can write invalid brain F code is if
you don't match your opening closing
braces up then we're going to have to
raise an error for that because that's
just not valid otherwise you can pretty
much put what you want in that file to
pillows and and so when we run this
program then now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna iterate over the program
string and we've got each character in
there sort of instruction set and then
call the function that we get back so
we're gonna say if you get a so quote
we're just gonna say okay Chuck it's
program exit just handle it somehow
interestingly you can put if you put
different characters into your brain F
code for instance to add comments about
what on earth is doing then that's
perfectly fine
by definition just ignores all of those
so we can skip them so let's go back to
our problem then we've got this brain F
language we think that we can use we've
we've got all strings to date how are we
gonna go on and think about evolving
programs so we're gonna have a few
problems now the beginning before so we
can potentially have in
the programmer says we've just seen if
you haven't matched up those square
braces and we can have programs that
never end if we're generating them
randomly
it was a decent chance something will
have an implement loop in it we're just
gonna have to define a cut-off point and
say if it's not stopped by then probably
it's not going to and time goes out in
over those cases we're going to give it
a super load at the school in order to
weed out those ones pretty quickly and
trying to get on to something that
actually produces some output so there's
not too much new code and because we can
still use a general-purpose from genetic
algorithm function that we had before
we just need to feed it some different
functions for interesting bits so
generating random programs this is just
a generating strings again I have rather
than just has the eight basic brain F
characters kind of put in some way
you've got many in a row otherwise it's
really frustrating watching it evolve
and put pluses and minuses alternately
you can select a route so to give it
some chance of actually doing something
useful I've kind of avoided the command
set a little bit breeding programs so
this will just be the same thing when we
cross over the strings again what I have
done is mate replace only false so if we
go back to how we were doing the
mutations you need to make this a little
bit more interesting for program codes
so what we've got here is rather than
the thing that we are evolving and
scoring the fitness being on the same in
this case we're gonna oh I should have
said well the program was going to do
about program to output I would have
hello world but that's probably not
going to converge in the time to talk so
this is going to do hi so we're gonna
figure out if we've got to that program
by looking at the output it produces and
seeing how close it is to our talk
output so this now means that the thing
we're scoring is a program output but
the thing we're evolving is brigham code
so we can have output that's potentially
very close but the program codes kind of
stuck in an off with local minima
somewhere so we need to get a bit more
of a kick essentially to get out those
so we introduced some sort of wider
variety of ways to mutate this so as
well as just replacing character
we're also going to say you can insert
them you can delete them that kind of
stuff
simile when we do the selection we will
oh it isn't library cool when we do the
selection we're gonna set the roulette
selection that we briefly came across
earlier to tree and so in that roulette
selection you can think about this it's
a kind of pie chart where each member of
the population is a wedge and it's gonna
have a larger wedge if that member has a
higher finish school and then we're
gonna kind of spin a spinner on it to
pick which one survive to the next round
so rather than just picking the fifth is
part off which might seem like a great
idea but then what kind of be a little
bit too elitist and narrow us down
really quickly on this path which might
ultimately not going anywhere we're
gonna let some of the ones with lower
scores have a chance of getting it to
the next generation too because that
pathway might actually lead to something
interesting in the end so we're gonna in
add that in so that's how we're gonna
read our programs and generate them
we're gonna stop when this toilet
program output is what we want in order
to calculate the fitness what we're
gonna do is run the program to grab that
output so we redirect about to grab it
as I said if it times out or if you get
this it can't run square braces don't
match up we're just gonna give it a
really really bad check school otherwise
we're gonna get the output and
calculates in this one so to calculate
Fitness again we're basically gonna
reward to the characters match and take
some off if the lenses don't that's
pretty much it so if we give that a go
and this is where we really do cross the
fingers because this is a random demo
and um so it's expected we're starting
off of a load of invalid stuff hopefully
they'll start to weed out
kind of expected if you just generating
random stuff outside square braces don't
match we should get to some output
reasonably quickly and con they're gonna
stick around letters that are closed in
the alphabet given how we did our
fitness going so that's that's evolving
some code which was just output some
text to screen
I was suspect for fun so I kind of
stopped at this point if you go back to
core --decor site she took a bit further
so generated code and brain F that would
calculate Fibonacci numbers taking input
numbers and add them up run through how
many green bottles of beer on the wall
two more numbers and any human would
have patience to count awesome on
testing things and genetic algorithm
rather than just evolving code which as
you can see no one wants to maintain
this code are probably not gonna start
writing it's not go replace me too soon
but they aren't they do have their uses
still so in terms of searching a really
large search space but you've got lots
of different parameters you want to tune
they're very helpful so friend I think I
first saw them I did my undergrad so I'm
not I didn't do this I did a chemistry
my following a project involved
molecular self-assembly and you
designing molecules such that they will
assemble into things and so you have to
decide well where will I put the
molecular binding sites on it and
there's so many options you can run
simulations where you use genetic
algorithms to try out lots of different
bots that you could put these binding
sites on and see what's gonna work and
then only make the molecules that will
work for all and spending those are time
the lab tryout similarly anything where
you've got lots of different parameters
that you ought to try options for so I
think I've seen someone they had lots of
hype of parameters for their neural
network I need to find some good values
somehow you could use a death counter
space another thing where lots of
parameters and you want to search to see
what's good so the code if Internet
the fan will get up what's on Twitter
but realistically I don't use Twitter so
probably don't bother running me on
Twitter but their github link is there
[Applause]